got you so this is how i was supposed to
move to england but the pandemic ruined
it i played division three basketball
and volleyball a year ago i was working
this sales job that i hated i hated so
much i've always kind of wanted to play
professional basketball or volleyball
overseas and i also always wanted to be
a youtuber i found a school in england
called bournemouth i could play semi-pro
basketball while also getting my masters
in digital media management the
program's a year long and typically if
you do well you can go play pro
basketball or volleyball the year after
but then
the pandemic hit i was supposed to leave
in september then season got pushed off
january no problem i was gonna go in
january plan was quit my job in october
leave in january that way i'd have three
months to get my youtube channel going
and spend time with family before i left
in october it looked like things were
going to get better but now my season's
been pushed to september again and i
have no job so i'm doing tick-tock and
youtube full-time